asus est venu cet après votre
démonstration et je dirais même votre
démonstration de force sur michael
jackson
les gens en redemandent
[Applaudissements]
ouais vraiment les gens en redemandent
aimerait une nouvelle démonstration de
force de michael jackson je suis la
corde dans un instant bien entendu on
parlera d'autre signé poteau trouvé
l'amour dans les émissions de dating on
a des grosses rigolades mandat du lourd
qui arrive prenez j'aimerais que vous
regardiez vraiment youssef c'est que
vous fassiez exactement la même chose un
peu plus d'habitude il fait hugues
aufray très bien fait à santiago comme
ça ici ou là c'est un autre délire
youssef basily je vais retourner
[Applaudissements]
je
ce 15 août c'est la patrie c'est
l'attitude du gard cantine et al il fait
achats mais chaque l'heure quand même
c'est bon hélas dès qu'il arrive là sur
ce cas mais venez ici j'ai regardé quand
il chante à 10,6 du blast et dès que
j'arrive
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les ados
[Applaudissements]
le ballet
ça c'est du bon ça c'est du lourd par
jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah bon
hu
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dix fois moins
à l'ailé fois
mais dieu bénisse à s'engueuler alors s
est exceptionnel